hi i'm christopher hine and i'm going to
talk to you about my 20 years of getting
beaten up with aikido
[Applause]
[Music]
so
if you've seen my previous video there's
a video right before this the video
talks about uh my experiences and my
journey in the beginning of my aikido
practice so i learned aikido at a large
aikido school became a black belt in
aikido then i got in a fight aikido
didn't work for me and so i then went
and started doing mixed martial arts and
brazilian jiu jitsu to figure out how to
make my aikido work in that my first two
years of doing that i realized that
aikido didn't work didn't work at all
then i got in a fight with the dog
brothers doing full contact stick
fighting and some aikido came out that
encouraged me to open up a small school
back in my hometown and start working on
aikido again and here there we smashed
each other against the garage over and
over and over
until we kind of figured out some of the
stuff of aikido so this video series
that we're in now is exploring my
journey through that the first part
talks about the beginning that i just
kind of recapped right there and then
this video is going to be about the
middle of that journey so
in the beginning michael veron and i
were sparring with this stuff all the
time wrestling around with weapons the
weapons changed the context for us so
all of a sudden we could see aikido
techniques i began to catalogue all of
the aikido techniques so i kept a little
journal that i would say today i got
kodage today i got shionage today i got
koshinagi etcetera so forth and
eventually i had all of the techniques
of aikido as i wanted to see them
meaning they naturally appeared like i
wasn't trying to just trying to get that
technique it meant that while we were in
the middle of our wrestling over weapons
then i got the techniques we soon
included the rest of the school in it so
first it was just michael and i who were
the teachers there and then we included
the rest of the students and got them
doing these kinds of things and we could
again see more and more techniques
naturally appear and i could start to
see them from people who hadn't spent
you know five six years doing aikido but
people who had just been doing aikido
for for less than a year actually doing
aikido techniques because the context
was so natural that they would appear
i had problems though so while i could
see things like sankyo and kodagayanikyo
there were lots of things i wasn't
seeing that i should have been seeing so
meaning that we would do lots and lots
of clinch work clinch work was
not
separable from the stuff we were doing
we were always doing clinches and clinch
work wasn't accounted for an iq at all
now you might think at this point well
that's because aikido was a poorly put
together martial art but i already
learned my lesson that it was not the
aikido that was the problem it was
context that was the problem because
once i fixed the context now i can see
aikido techniques so i thought i still
don't understand the context
other questions started to arise one of
the questions and things i was working
on was how do i actually get to the guy
with
the knife so understand that i'm seeing
aikido as an armed grappling system at
this point but i'm really predominantly
working from the assumption that it must
be the unarmed guy learning to deal with
the armed guy right so how do i get to
that armed guy and we started running
lots of drills if you've ever had a
practice like this you realize that when
someone has a weapon it's really
difficult to get to them without getting
cut severely regularly so this is a real
problem when you're looking at it as
being the unarmed guy trying to deal
with the armed guy but again going back
to understanding what wrist grabs do
this starts to
illustrate something to us and that's
that the eye kiddo person the person
doing nigel techniques they're the one
who's having their wrist grab so they're
training for the unlikely situation that
someone actually catches your wrist so
this really started to change things for
me and i started to realize this and
this led to some other problems that i
was having so i started trying to figure
out why in the world there would not be
clinches now luckily for me i began
working on another problem at exactly
the same time and that problem was
multiple attackers
i quickly quickly learned that
even when my students were way smaller
than me and less trained than me and not
as able as me
they still in numbers could take me down
right so multiples of them would still
take me down and i realized that if they
got a hold of me and we went into any
kind of hold held position
i might be able to force my way out
because i'm a lot stronger but
it's going to be a real fight and if
those guys were the same skill level and
size as me there's no way every time i
would lose
i put this together with the weapon
context issues and started to realize
that instead of being kind of what i
imagined it to be and this is because
this is what's in movies and stuff right
in movies the good guy throws his knife
away and then he you know does some some
special martial arts moves to win the
day
i realized that that was the kind of
context i was trying to force so when i
understood aikido as a weapon system i
understood it as oh i must be unarmed
and i'm trying to deal with an armed guy
that led to clinches and it led to a
reasonable amount of success but once i
started to realize that actually it was
the other way around and that the aikido
person should be the armed person that
changed things so if you're in a
situation where bigger stronger people
are trying to hurt you you're going to
use a weapon and that was the context
that ikeda was talking about the only
way you're going to be able to handle
multiple attackers is if you have a
weapon that can do so much serious
damage that it will hurt and stop the
other people immediately
so i flipped the context of what we were
doing and started making the nage the
person who was armed and the unarmed
people the people who were attacking
now my complete objective set changed i
no longer wanted to see clinch work
because if i clinched that meant as soon
as i was holding clinching with one
person another person would come in and
get me and i couldn't use my weapon as
effectively in the clinch as i could at
a distance so by making the aikido
person the armed person all of a sudden
i flipped the context and we see why
aikido doesn't have clinch work you
shouldn't be in the clinch and in fact
aikido is working from the lighter holds
this answered another big problem that
i'd had for a long time so one of the
big problems i had was
dodori right so body grabs like katadori
munador
these things didn't fit into my previous
context the reason they didn't fit in
there is because those positions were so
transitory they only happen for a split
second now that doesn't change when we
go to multiple attackers however those
split seconds become very very valuable
split seconds that you have to master
meaning if someone grabs your shoulder
you're only going to have a split second
until someone else is on top of you and
able to bring you down so you have to
master that split second of how to get
clear of that grab so instead of
increasing the clinch we need to break
out of anything that could possibly lead
to a clinch so by changing my mindset
here i have all of a sudden started to
understand a whole lot more of aikido
these middle years are pretty much where
i realized how the context of aikido
worked now i still was missing some
philosophical pieces and that wouldn't
be put together till later until i
actually started to work on a school
that wasn't in my garage which was
basically a fight club where we smashed
each other against the wall once i got
into a public school and i was working
with older people and kids then the
philosophical elements started to really
come to me and i put together the final
piece of this but at this stage i had
realized that aikido did involve weapons
but it involved you having the weapon
because you would need a weapon if
people are bigger and stronger than you
if a world's greatest ufc fighter wanted
to come and fight you you would
definitely have a weapon you wouldn't
want to go box with him or wrestle with
him because you know you're going to
lose that right with a weapon maybe you
stand a chance what increases your
chance well if he can't get a hold of
you to smash you because even with a
weapon if that guy can close the
distance really quick and hold you so
you can't use the weapon he's going to
dominate you so you need to study a
martial art that teaches you to maximize
that time where you're free and moving
around my phase one was thinking aikido
was basically japanese jiu jitsu and
then realizing there was too much
missing in it to be japanese jiu jitsu
and the japanese jiu jitsu wouldn't work
in multiple attacker situations or a
situation where a guy was bigger and
better than you and aikido needed to
answer those kinds of questions so i
moved that to this kind of mobile weapon
platform which is what i started to
think aikido was where
using the weapon was the agenda and
aikido was just a system to help you
stay autonomous so you could stay free
and move around and use your weapon
right now if you think about that in a
modern context to me that seemed really
really useful because like if i had a
pistol and i'm moving around and people
are trying to attack me i could use the
pistol while i'm moving around to stay
free and the same would be true for the
samurai back in the day with their
swords knives naginatas whatever weapons
they have and so this is probably the
kind of mindset you ishiba had if we're
going to deal with multiple attackers we
have to have a weapon so i was looking
at aikido as a mobile weapon platform
there's another face so this is my phase
two phase three is me starting to
understand how the philosophy of aikido
ties to this because understand this is
supposed to be a peaceful martial art so
how does this peaceful martial art tie
into this mobile weapon platform right
that definitely doesn't sound like a
peaceful martial art so in the third
series i'm going to talk about how i put
it together and got a complete
understanding for myself in aikido
through all the live training we were
doing all right i would like to say
thank you to all my patrons who really
helped make my videos possible right so
they helped me get new equipment and
help me live my regular life so thanks a
lot to all my patrons i appreciate you
guys if you're interested in regular
videos from me um going to patreon is
the way to do that because i just kind
of make youtube videos as the whim
strikes me if i feel like making a
youtube video i make a youtube video or
series otherwise i'm weekly making
videos over here on patreon so you can
go to patreon and become one of my
patrons and that would be much
appreciated i'm christopher hines stay
tuned for the third installment in this
series where i talk about how i actually
figure out what aikido is aside from a a
mobile weapon platform and use it in
another way and that actually ties
together the philosophy of aikido and
what we were doing at the dojo
[Music]